bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur France 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
est Mireille oppo dolia qui les
conseillé du président
ukrainien volodimeki il est avec nous
depuis Kiev merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous merci à vous
monsieur podelia que les offensives les
contre-offensives devrais-je dire
ukrainienne se poursuivent à la fois
dans le Dombas c'est dans la région de
rerson plus au sud alors tout d'abord
dans le Dombas après la reprise par
l'Ukraine de la ville de Limane qui est
dans la région de doniac c'est désormais
la région de luganz qui est dans le
viseur est-ce que c'est le prochain
objectif dans cette région de vos forces
militaires
[Musique]
comme ça discuter des projets de
l'état-major de l'Ukraine effectivement
pour que
ne pas
dire des choses à l'ennemi nous
avons plusieurs
activités de contrefensif sur
différentes directions sur Denia sur le
gain sur carcov
une petite un petit territoire il reste
quelques pourcentages de la région de
kakov qu'on va libérer et après donc on
sort vers sur la région de Lugansk en ce
qui concerne les régions de Kerson nous
avons quatre particularités de notre
contratensive nous frappons tout d'abord
les infrastructures de
d'état-major russe et nous nous cassons
aussi les arrières russes c'est pour ça
que leur résistance est assez comme ça
que le résistance est affaibli en même
temps nous frappons sur différentes
directions ce qui disciple l'attention
des Russes disciplent les troupes russes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas assez de réserve
ils savent pas comment les
[Musique]
mieux nous avons vu déjà que liée le
contingent déjà très mal préparé très
incontinent mal préparé
parce que les
professionnels dans lesquels on a ils
ont investi beaucoup il y en a presque
plus maintenant sur le terrain et donc
4e chose grâce à la destruction de la
phrase structure de l'armée russe de
leur logistique il sont beaucoup moins
efficaces en ce qui concerne le
contre-feu leur contrefeu et je dois
dire que ici nous voyons
la préparation différente
des troupes entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine est très concentré et très
motivé et les Russes sont un peu perdus
alors d'après ce que vous dites
évidemment on va pas discuter de
stratégie militaire aujourd'hui mais
clairement la ville de Kerson qui est
une capitale régionale d'une des
premières à avoir été prise par les
Russes dorénavant l'Ukraine est proche
de reprendre cette ville de Kerson dans
les jours qui viennent monsieur podeliac
re est plus que capable de
reprendre eckerson c'est la guerre il y
a ça on peut pas dire que lundi mardi la
semaine prochaine car ça sera repris par
par l'Ukraine et sera parti de la
juridiction à nouveau de l'Ukraine la
question est ailleurs il y a un certain
nombre de facteurs qui déterminent la
guerre parmi ces facteurs ce sont des
livraisons d'armement il faut que les
armements arrivent à temps le volume de
ces armements est très important aussi
de ces livraisons donc il y a plusieurs
facteurs qui peuvent influencer aussi la
météo peut influencer beaucoup donc soit
ça peut accélérer soit pas peur ralentir
l'avancement de nos forces il y a aussi
les questions liées au relief du terrain
lorsque nous parlons de Kerson il s'agit
des steppes d'une région où il y a que
des steps donc là-bas c'est il est
beaucoup plus efficace de frapper à
l'autre allons par des par nos canaux
par des artériori qui permet
effectivement détruire les accumulations
des troupes russes la Russie se bat
d'une façon concentrée et c'est de
réunir les troupes suivant la stratégie
des années 60-70 pour pouvoir avancer
après donc
des armements efficaces à moyenne et
l'ont porté peuvent détruire ces
accumulations de troupes russes et après
accélérer notre contre-offensive mais
beaucoup dépend de la météo de la
logistique de la livraison des obus des
obus des munitions et en plus il faut
qu'on avance
tenant compte des réserves aussi de la
verrue qui doit être qui doivent être
détruites sur les chemins adjacents
mais de façon plus générale vous aviez
dit il y a quelques semaines que
l'Ukraine pouvait gagner cette guerre
beaucoup de gens ont pensé que vous
rêviez un petit peu est-ce que là de
façon réaliste évidemment le calendrier
varie en raison du climat du relief et
des livraisons d'armes mais est-ce que
là de façon réaliste vous pensez
réellement que l'Ukraine peut reprendre
tous les territoires conquis depuis le
24 février dans les semaines qui
viennent
c'est une question très importante c'est
une question clé qui détermine comment
l'Europe sera d'ici un an d'ici 6 mois
elle s'est agit du choix que l'Ukraine
avait fait chez nous pour pour préserver
notre état
donc effectivement nous nous sommes il y
a une un précipice il y a un fossé
civilisationnel entre nous c'est un
mythe de dire que nous sommes le même
peuple nous on est des peuples très
différents les 6 mois de guerre montrent
que le crâne se perfectionne tout le
temps en ce qui concerne l'état lui-même
en ce qui concerne les livraisons
d'armement ce qui est concerne notre
efficacité de combat si pendant les
premiers mois nous avons été très
efficaces en défense tout en manœuvrant
ce qui a empêcher les Russes de passer
avec leurs chars partout dans le pays
donc le scénario russe avait échoué mais
aujourd'hui nous nous montrons au monde
une contre-infensive très efficace sur
différentes directions et je pense que
les
l'opinions publiques chez nos
partenaires dans les en Europe et
compris en France a beaucoup changé
maintenant il y a une les gens
comprennent que on est capable de
gagner cette guerre donc en fait
d'avoir une
victoire tactique la Russie va perdre
les territoires
occupés en Ukraine ils vont perdre aussi
la
Crimée et le don de basse
nous voulons pas avoir des enclaves
criminels qui seraient qui présenterait
une
menace potentielle et ses menaces ce
sont des j'ai réalisées puisqu'il y a la
guerre donc la Russie ne pourra plus
utiliser ses enclaves pour commencer la
guerre contre l'Ukraine et contre
l'Europe donc avec nos partenaires y
compris avec la France nous sommes plus
près en ce qui concerne les ressources
de gagner tactiquement cette guerre nous
comprenons maintenant très bien comment
les guerres modernes sont menées on est
préparé moralement aussi beaucoup mieux
en ce qui concerne le consensus en
Ukraine plus de 90% de population en
Ukraine parce que la guerre doit être
gagnée grâce à la libération de tous les
territoires y compris jusqu'au donc
frontières internationalement reconnu de
l'Ukraine donc nos partenaires et
nous-mêmes nous comprenons très bien
qu'il faut on peut gagner la guerre que
qu'une seule que d'un seul moyen d'une
d'une seule façon la Russie doit quitter
l'Ukraine complètement et si la Russie
décide d'utiliser des armes yes
nucléaires tactiques est-ce que les
chats
théorique ou est-ce que vous avez des
informations qui indiquent la Russie y
pense sérieusement que Vladimir Poutine
considère que il peut utiliser cela en
raison de ses déconvenues sur le terrain
malheureusement
ce qui se passe en Russie et on savait
pas ce que pensent les élites c'est un
analyse n'a pas été faite
en fait on est très sérieux par rapport
à tout ce qui dit par la Russie nous
sommes nous nous combattons avec mais je
voudrais mettre des points sur les îles
pour comprendre la situation regardez la
Fédération de Russie d'une façon
unilatérale entre sur le territoire en
Ukraine et mène une guerre
conventionnelle en Ukraine la Russie a
utilisé tous les tous les moyens de
guerre sauf l'armement nucléaire les
avions les les blindés des canons de
différents calibres tout a été utilisé
l'Ukraine a commencé à libérer
activement son territoire ce qui ce qui
veut dire que la Russie peut facilement
peu perdre cette guerre et perd déjà et
donc le pays
comme l'Ukraine nous ne sont pas un pays
nucléaire donc qui est menacé maintenant
par les armes nucléaires en tant que les
armements nucléaires offensives d'une
façon
préventive contre un état qui n'est pas
nucléaire donc la Fédération de Russie
devant le monde entier casse la
construction qui a été établie
concernant la sécurité nucléaire il y a
une doctrine de sécurité nucléaire qui
prévoit que les États nucléaires ne
peuvent pas utiliser les armoires
nucléaires offensives contre les pays
qui sont pas nucléaire eux-mêmes donc
c'est une chose fondamentale qui est
garantit le traité de non prolifération
du nucléaire des armements nucléaires
six pays de qui ont des armées
nucléaires de tous les cas libres donc
si c'est très torique russe continue je
pense que les États qui sont nucléaires
les autres États nucléaires pour
expliquer à la Russie clairement quels
sont les conséquences qui attendent la
Russie dans cette situation puisque le
crâne ne dispose pas de d'armement
nucléaire donc la Russie doit comprendre
même si tu perds la guerre
conventionnelle tu peux pas utiliser la
guerre nucléaire autrement tous les
autres États vont sortir du traité de
dons prolifération comprenant que
n'importe quel pays nucléaire peut
prendre la moitié de leur territoire ou
un morceau de territoire dire que c'est
leur territoire à eux et si les autres
résistent et commencer veulent
faire revenir ce territoire à eux on
utilise l'armement nucléaire donc c'est
inadmissible donc c'est ici ceci doit
être réglé au niveau des pays nucléaires
donc on peut pas autoriser à la Russie
de d'ignorer le cette architecture de
sécurité donc casser la dissuasion
nucléaire Mireille podeliak merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu aux questions
de France 24 depuis qui est et merci
beaucoup à vous d'avoir regardé cette
entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]